I'm mad
I'm just really mad
I'm I'm mad that lawmakers won't take
this seriously
you think it's not going to happen in
your town and then it does we've heard
that before
when is it going to stop we've heard
that before it has to end we've heard
that before
who's going to do something about it
we've heard that before
it just keeps happening over and over
this is the only country in the world
where this keeps happening we've heard
that before
there's nothing there's nothing that you
can say that we haven't heard
from parents and victims and cities
for decades now and
nothing changes we've heard that before
are you exhausted
foreign
I'm just really mad
I'm I'm mad that lawmakers won't take
this seriously
I'm mad that I had to leave our school
and hug our head of the school
[Music]
I'm mad that everyone else is mad
for a week
that's it
I'm mad that
for this week you'll see on social media
everyone is outraged you'll hear
thoughts and prayers
for a week
and then you hear about gun rights
and you hear about politics
but what about
these kids right to life
what about the custodians right to life
what about the substitute teachers right
to life for the head of schools right to
life
what about those parents
you take your children to school you put
them in a cute little uniform
and you send them to a very nice
private school or a very nice Public
School
and it doesn't matter where you send
your kids it doesn't matter the good
neighborhood that you live in
it doesn't matter you still send your
kids fearful and I went to school today
and I looked at that door
I look at the door
and I thought can we get steel doors in
a school
but then the kids are outside playing at
activity time and at recess
we have a shortage of mental health
professionals I'm a physician myself I'm
a pediatrician so I know that
child mental health adult mental health
is very lacking in this country
but a mentally unstable or a mentally
unhealthy person can only do so much
with a stick or with a rock or with a
knife
a mentally unstable person with seven
assault rifles
can get into a locked door
can get in through a metal door
can get past security
can shoot police who are trying to
protect the community
that's the problem
foreign